[Musik]
in deutschland viele kunstschätze aus
der region meine heimat sind vor vielen
jahren nach deutschland gebracht worden
sie hatten eine sehr viel angenehmer
weise alles ist sie brauchten keine
reisepass schafften den sprung
oberligist gleich beim ersten mal und
die grenze waren geöffnet
aber trotzdem
heute sind diese kunstschätze und ich in
berlin
ich bin aus hamburg gekommen und hoffe
dass ich meine originalteil finden
können
[Musik]
auch der damaligen prozessionsstraße
nähere ich mich dem tor
hier haben die babylonier ihre neue
jahres feste gefeiert
viele besucher erfreuen sich an diese
straße und dem tor einige werden
neugierig auf die gestiegene herkunft
[Musik]
und ich freue ich mich dass dort sehe ja
natürlich freue ich mich ich bin ganz
glücklich das original in der stadt und
einige originale kunstschätze aus der
haft zu besichtigen
mit meinem team besucher ist frau
professor abba helden und tag
wir wollen so wir sind zu einem gespräch
verabredet
ich möchte wissen wie diese monument den
nach deutschland gekommen sind
die geschichte ist so dass es war kein
archäologe der den tell halaf
ausgegraben hat der tell halaf ist in
nordsyrien es ist eigentlich genau da in
der gegend von russell ein
das war ein diplomat ein deutscher max
von oppenheim und max von oppenheim hat
zwischen 1911 und 1913 am tell halaf
ausgegraben und dann kam der erste
weltkrieg dann wurde die grabung
geschlossen die sachen blieben erstmal
dort wurde hat der 1927
da gab es dann das osmanische reich und
nicht mehr da war dann das gebiet das
heute syrien ist unter französischer
verwaltung und mit einer antiken
direktion die eben von den franzosen
geführt wurde und dann hat er eine
vereinbarung unterzeichnet und an
auf der grundlage dieser vereinbarung
hat er 1927 die teilhabe skulptur nach
berlin gebracht
mit genehmigung genau mit genehmigung
und dann kam er hierher und wollte sie
dem museum verkaufen und das museum hat
gesagt ist uns viel zu teuer und
daraufhin hatte max von oppenheim sein
eigenes museum eröffnet und er hat das
in einem alten fabrikgebäude in
charlottenburg getan hat die skulpturen
alle so auf geschäfts gibt also auch auf
fotos aus dieser aus dieser ausstellung
die berliner haben das ganz toll
gefunden
diese skulpturen bestaunt also das war
an der stelle schon eine botschaft aus
einer für die berliner sehr sehr fremden
welt und das museum hat also reichlich
besucher gehabt aber es war nicht hier
auf der museumsinsel sondern eben in
charlottenburg und das muss ja mal 143
zerbombt worden
ich habe ja gesagt 'denk männer sammeln
eine geschichte sie sind heute auch
denke ich zeichen von hoffnung wenn man
sieht wie kaputt berlin war nach dem
krieg und dass man eben nicht nur die
häuser sondern sogar auf dem modell
intel wieder restaurieren kann es
braucht zeit es braucht geduld es
braucht auch das können das wissen um
das braucht natürlich geld immer aber
durch diese geschichte transportieren
sie auch noch mal
sie haben sozusagen wieder eine schicht
geschichte mehr dazu bekommen die wir
heute menschen auch berührt im museum
treffe ich einen alten kollegen den ich
noch aus öhringen das ist ein
emotionaler moment und wir spielen in
erinnerung
ich war nie woran liegt das es erinnert
mich an das monument in damaskus
wenn ich hier herumlaufen habe ich große
lust eine tour zu leiten wir müssen sie
die touren in damaskus
ja sehr ich habe 35 jahre als
reiseleiter gearbeitet und dann sagt man
mir ich solle zu hause bleiben weil es
keine arbeit mehr für mich gibt es wenn
man seine reisegruppe sagen muss dass
das monument eine kopie ist und das
organ basting
leider haben uns viel schlimmes angetan
auch unsere kunstschätze haben sie uns
genommen
wenn ich so daran denke und sind nur
kopien geblieben die originale sind in
berlin
ich sage immer sie müssen ins
pergamonmuseum gehen lassen sich die
originale anzusehen die leute haben mir
immer gesagt das pergamonmuseum ist
wunderschön
ich freue mich jetzt hier zu sein auch
wenn es gegen meinen willen der schaft
moment der sind mehr als nur mono mit
system vor eine identität
sie sind das wir vor 5000 jahren in dem
land war
sie sind unsere identität unsere
geschichte unsere zivilisation und
unsere vergangenheit jeder mensch ist
stolz auf seine vergangenheit und diese
vergangenheit muss zurück in unser land
es sind unsere vorfahren die am ufer des
euphrat und des tigris gelebt haben in
damaskus seine vergangenheit mehr hat
auch deine zukunft ohne vergangenheit
deine zukunft stellen sie sich mal vor
das brandenburger tor in berlin
wer eine kopie und das original wäre in
aleppo im museum ausgestellt das ist
eine schöne idee aber ist das nicht ein
bisschen schwierig ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass jemand ein tor nach
syrien verlegen würde
wenn dann würde sie eine führung durch
das brandenburger tor im nationalmuseum
in allegro machen wie finden sie die
deutschen würden mich lieben was denken
die museumsbesucher darüber und da ist
die monumente da sind ja es ist
schwierig
ich meine man spricht darüber soll die
nofretete in deutschland bleiben oder
solche zurück nach sind immer schwierige
fragen natürlich kann man sagen ist auch
deutsche kunst irgendwo anders im
ausland ja ich glaube solange die kunst
zugänglich ist ist es in ordnung die
frage ist wie kann man in den besitz war
es legal oder was illegal ist geklaut
worden dass es damals legal geholt
worden
die stabilität ist natürlich das lange
diskutieren wie gesagt ich finde es ist
wahnsinnig wichtig zu sagen warum woher
wieso und meine es ist ganz wichtig
heutzutage alles zu erklären also
verstanden wie man vor
das waren die bürger vor
ich habe daher eine kopie und die
original ist so riesig ist
das sind mit mehreren
kiwi geführt werden oder wenn leute
irgendetwas finden
und das mit und andere länder
der fall dass das original sich was
befindet
das ist teil der kultur kommt
dass das hier nicht das buch von
deutschen
vorfahren war ist gerade
selbstverständlich trotzdem verstehe ich
das wenn man darüber brüssel eine
verrückte nacht in der die leute sich
umarmt haben andere auf der mauer
standen ungeschlagen durch ganz
aufgehoben haben oder an der größe
standen um die patientin mit freude zu
empfangen
ich habe mir immer vorgestellt dass ich
so empfinde wenn ich das brandenburger
tor sie für mich bedeutet es einheiten
wille und hoffnung aber was wird das
brandenburger tor für sie
als botschaft quasi vielleicht klar ich
meine erinnert natürlich an die die
geschichte von daher kann man sich
natürlich gerade wenn man hier lebt
dann immer vor augen halten zum einen
was damit verbunden ist und was man
damit mitnehmen kann dann vielleicht
einfach auch versuchen an lösungen zu
arbeiten miteinander klarzukommen und
eben nicht zu spalten zu teilen
ob das ist eine stadt der ist ob das
religion ist ob das weiß ich nicht
andere länder sind wie auch immer
kulturen dass man einfach einigkeit
bekommen kann und was sagen das kann man
dann irgendwie daraus ziehen es wie
gesagt sowohl der der einigung oder
einigkeit
ich glaube es ist ein großer teil der
identität es zieht viele touristen an
es wäre ziemlich schwierig wenn man die
säule verlieren würde wenn man sich
zurück schicken wird
ich denke man muss darüber reden wie
wichtig es für die länder ist so etwas
in seinem heimatland zurückzubringen
solche großen momente sind ein wichtiger
grund warum menschen die länder besuchen
sie wollen mehr über die kultur erfahren
ich finde es wichtig das zu respektieren
wenn etwas gestohlen wurde ist es
vielleicht wichtig es zurückzugeben und
darüber zu sprechen haben die russen
haben mit ihr um die amis mitgenommen
die deutschen haben haben sie nichts
vorzuwerfen
sie haben sich nichts vorzuwerfen die
russen haben mitgenommen die deutsche
hall mitgenommen und da soll einen
kreislauf sein wenn wir uns nicht
infrage stellen kann diese kreislauf nie
einhalten es würde für immer so weiter
laufen dass wir unsere menschlichkeit
verlieren
das war nicht das erste mal dass ich
diesen satz gehört haben aber es war
indira frau professor helbing hat mir
gesagt dass damals mit genehmigung der
franzosen genommen wurde
aber ich weiß nicht ob professor hält
wegen sich gefragt hat ob die franzosen
die erlaubnis hatten meine zivilisation
und identität syriens an deutschland
weiter zu geben hat sie sich gefragt
die koloniale regierung die rechtmäßige
regierung war ich war auch eine suche
nach meinem originalteil aber jetzt bin
ich auf der suche nach menschen die mich
verstehen und diesen kreislauf mit mehr
beenden wollen die mutig sind sich
selbst im spiegel anzusehen und ich bin
ganz glücklich dass ich viele gefunden
haben die verstehen warum die sonne
förmlich aus dem westen scheint
[Musik]